hey there oh we're back from University
of Utah and president Trump is actually
nominating some good judges plus did he
just defeat the NFL and is that good for
America or just good for president Trump
we'll talk about it I'm Ben Shapiro this
is the Ben Shapiro show well we do have
a big mailbag coming up today and I've
looked at the questions and some of them
are just at Susie's some of them are
pretty amazing so it'll get to all of
your questions today in the mailbag if
you were a subscriber you too could have
been part of the mailbag you know life
would have been that much richer but if
you're not I guess that you'll just have
to listen to everybody else's problems
be solved while you wallow through your
own we'll get to all of that in just a
little while plus President Trump is
actually winning the battle against the
NFL we're going to talk about what it
means for him to win whether that is the
country winning or just Trump winning
what are the costs and the benefits of
that happening because a lot of people
on the right are very excited that it
seems like the right is finally winning
the culture war I'm not sure that the
right was losing this particular aspect
of the culture war already I just think
that it hadn't been brought to sort of
the fore so we'll talk about that but
first I want to say thank you to our
sponsors over at Birch gold so there's a
lot of uncertainty in the foreign policy
sphere every couple of days
Rocketman seems to be threatening us
with nuclear war there are natural
disasters that seem to be striking the
United States an outsized rate you don't
have to be that worried about these
things to know that it's probably a good
idea to have some food in your house in
case things go bad in case you can't get
to the grocery store because there's
some sort of emergency or in case the
shelves are cleaned out and the
government can't get to you and that's
why you should go over to Birch gold and
you should make sure that you are also
prepped in terms of economics okay we
talk all the time on this show about how
you should be prepared for emergency
well when it comes to things like
natural disasters or foreign policy
problems or business problems insecurity
in the stock market it is necessary for
you to have at least part of your money
in a solid asset like gold like precious
metals not all your money but you should
diversify and some of your money should
be in precious metals right now if you
contact Birch gold group they will give
you a free information get a
comprehensive 16 page kit showing how
gold and silver can protect your savings
how you can legally move your IRA or
401k out of risky stocks and bonds and
into a precious metals IRA again I I do
have some of my money in precious metals
and birch gold those are the people that
I trust get your
no cost no obligation kit at
birchgold.com slash Ben that's
birchgold.com slash Ben asked all the
questions you're going to and then get
all your answers from the Birch gold
people again they can help you move your
money from an IRA or eligible for 1k
into an IRA backed by physical gold or
silver they have an A+ rating from the
Better Business Bureau a bunch of
five-star ratings from their clients
they're the people that they know how to
do this the best so ask all your
questions get all your answers and then
when you feel secure invest in precious
metals with Birch gold
okay so president Trump looks like he's
beginning to win big on the NFL what I
mean is that a lot of teams are now
backing down and this is why I really
think it had less to do with President
Trump purposefully picking a smart fight
and much more to do with the left's
knee-jerk reaction to everything Trump
says and then going over the top no
matter what Trump says so to
recapitulate what exactly happened here
for those who have been in sleep
indicated for the last couple of weeks
President Trump said that Colin
Kaepernick was an sob and that owners
should fire players who kneel on the
sidelines for the national anthem now if
you or I said that we're private
citizens the President of the United
States is the President of the United
States governmental actors should not be
telling private actors how to do their
business
it's just bad policy it is not good for
the country if the shoe were on the
other foot and Barack Obama were telling
people on the right that they should be
fired by their left-leaning employers we
would be justifiably angry okay but what
Trump wasn't wrong about is that it's
nasty to Neal for the national anthem it
is nasty to Neal for the national anthem
in 2017 okay we're not talking about in
1961 in the middle of Jim Crow even then
the the smartest civil rights leaders
people like Martin Luther King knew that
the smart thing to do would be to and
the right thing to do would be to claim
the mantle of the of the national anthem
and the star-spangled banner
rather than ripping on it and trying to
divide the country along those lines
today in 2017 there really is no excuse
for kneeling for the national anthem if
you have problems of the specific police
department then protest that police
department if you have a problem with a
specific police officer protests that
police officer but to suggest that
America is through-and-through a racist
sexist bigoted homophobic country like
that is that is guilty as a whole for
the sins of a few is is really it's
really quite nasty and it imputes nasty
intent to everybody who's standing for
the national anthem because if they
cared enough they'd kneel to okay so
that's where Trump was right where Trump
right is when he says that it's nasty to
kneel from the national anthem
disrespectful to the flag disrespectful
to people who have fought and died to
protect that flag and stand for that
national anthem there he is right but he
did what he does and he went too far and
I think is that a strategy is that by
accident I would say it's more by
accident because Trump has never seen a
moderate comment I Trump intact parted
ways long ago if ever they have met so
he says what he says and the left
because they're really done they decide
that instead of reacting by saying
listen we may agree about the national
anthem but everybody has a right to
express themselves the way they want to
and we don't think people should be
fired for doing that in the NFL and then
standing up for the national anthem
while some people kneel that would been
the smart thing to do instead what they
did is they started to kneel and they
allowed Trump to polarize this debate so
now instead of this being sort of a a
messy debate where some people were
against kneeling but against Trump and
some people were for Trump but for Trump
and against kneeling instead of that
what you had was instead this is this
weird situation where everyone who was
against kneeling was against Trump oh
sorry everyone who was for kneeling was
against Trump and everyone who was
against kneeling was for Trump Trump
placed himself squarely on the side of
the flag in the anthem and his
opposition was politically stupid enough
to allow him to create that dichotomy by
kneeling with the people who are
kneeling so now it looked like all the
people who are on Trump's side like the
flag in like the anthem and all the
people who weren't on Trump side hate
the flag and hate the anthem when half
the protest was actually about Trump not
about the anthem at all really really
dumb of left and now it's beginning to
pay dividends for Trump because Trump
stayed on this issue he realized this
was a popular issue he realized that
most Americans don't like people
kneeling he realized that if he could
grab the mantle of the flag in the
national anthem then he would end up
winning that debate because people like
the flag in the national anthem more
than they like the people who are
kneeling and if the last election proved
nothing it should have proved that we
are all binary thinkers or at least a
huge number of Americans or binary
thinkers we can't think in three
dimensions since that means that instead
of thinking about two issues at once
censorship of people who kneel and the
actual kneeling we just boil it down to
the actual kneeling and the left was
again dumb enough to fall for this so so
bryant gumbel over on HBO the left
thought that they had won this debate
which is an amazing thing if there are
bunch of people I'm left hanging on
Trump made a big boo-boo here I've been
saying since the big
this Trump did not make a big boo-boo
what I think Trump did was not great for
the country because I think there was a
broad consensus 85% of Americans don't
like kneeling and a similar number of
people are fine with with people not
being fired for kneeling right so
there's a pretty broad consensus Trump
split that consensus I don't think it's
good to split that consensus because I
agree with both halves of that hole but
the left immediately jumped into bed
with the Colin Kaepernick crowd and
here's Brian Gumbel saying that he
thinks that great the athletes are all
energized now now for sure they're gonna
win this battle really dumb stuff from
Brian Gumbel over on HBO finally tonight
a quick thanks to the current occupant
of the White House for energizing the
social conscience of the modern American
athlete that occupants weekend series of
racist cherish and childish comments
drew a variety of stunning rebukes and
actions which suggest jocks may finally
be realizing that apathy won't cut it
anymore that in conjunction with their
fame they have important civic roles to
play especially now not just willing but
also eager to follow in the giant
footsteps of Muhammad Ali Jim Brown Bill
Russell Billie Jean King Roberto
Clemente Arthur Ashe and many others who
courageously used their athletic
platforms to challenge authority in the
pursuit of justice okay let me stop for
a second so first of all I think that
it's important to note that a lot of the
people who we now Heil as you know
heroes in this in this area I'm thinking
specifically hear of Muhammad Ali where
at the time not seen that way and
there's a bit of a heavy golden gloss
that's being put on Muhammad Ali's
history I mean at the time he was deeply
associated with the radical racist
Nation of Islam and under under under
primo Farrakhan Elijah Muhammad and the
idea that he was doing some sort of
great service to the country Muhammad
Ali at the time I really disagree with
that pretty strongly in fact many
Americans disagreed with it which is why
when he had his first fight with Joe
Frazier a lot of Americans were on the
side of Joe Frazier
Muhammad Ali helped exacerbate racial
divides Joe Frazier was a guy who grew
up poor in Philadelphia
Muhammad Ali grew up middle class in
Louisiana as Cassius Clay and Joe
Frazier was somebody who didn't agree
with the idea that you were supposed to
stand against the American flag or that
you weren't that you were supposed to
protest the American government or that
America was a deeply terrible place
much more unifying figure than Ali Ali
proceeded to call Frazier a gorilla and
in use really racist terminology with
regard to Joe Frazier in order to in
order to push basically the Nation of
Islam's message so now he's hailed some
sort of civil rights hero but at the
time and certainly was not and a lot of
the stuff he did was really really
negative there's actually a great HBO
documentary on this called ghost of
Manila that you should go check out if
you haven't seen it it's also a book
that it's really worth reading on this
but beyond that if Brian Gumbel thinks
that the sports world is going to win by
continuing to politicize itself in ways
that are really not well thought out or
well calibrated that athletes doing
simplistic things like kneeling for the
national anthem is somehow great for the
country this is a battle that Brian
Gumbel and those and those athletes are
not going to win and I'm frankly
confused as to why they think they would
most Americans don't believe that this
is a racist country or should be
castigated as such most Americans also
believe that if you can name a specific
racist incident and will fight it with
you but he's not the only one so there's
a Titans at Tennessee Titans tight-end
named Delanie Walker who according to
The Tennessean said first off I'm going
to say this we're not disrespecting the
military the men and women that served
in the Army that's not what this is
about
if you look at most of the guys in here
I've been in the USO I support the
troops this is not about that it's about
equal rights and that's all everyone is
trying to show is that we all care about
each other and the fans that don't want
to come to the game I mean okay bye
could you possibly be dumber I mean why
are why in the world would you want to
alienate your fan base they are paying
your salary what we've seen over the
past couple of years is people not
watching ESPN I think in large measure
because it has become politicized people
not watching the NFL as much for a
couple of reasons first of all the the
worries about concussions second of all
of domestic violence stuff and then also
yes the politicization of the NFL I used
to watch a lot more NFL I don't like
watching the NFL as much anymore because
I don't need Bob Costas lecturing me on
gun control and I don't need a bunch of
st. Louis Rams players perpetuating the
lie that hands up don't shoot was a real
thing in Ferguson which they did a
couple of years ago and were not
punished by the NFL you see this from
people in the NBA to the 76ers their
first-round draft pick is gonna in Ben
Simmons he's supposed to be a very good
player and he comes out and he starts
ripping Trump by name and play that in
just a second and suggest that this is
not smart strategy and you will see that
Trump is going to
this particular battle which is a big
win for Trump we'll talk about whether
it's win for the right and a win for the
culture because I think it's not quite
as easy as some people want to make it
out to be but first I want to say thank
you to our sponsors over the u.s.
concealed-carry Association so someone
breaks into your house somebody somebody
is at the front door and they shatter
the window on your front door they reach
in they pull the latch you rush out with
your gun the person is try and get in
your house in the middle of the night
you shoot them you think that's the end
of the story you did a great job right
you did something good self defense
defensive home and others defend defends
himself and others defending your
property the police will come and they
may arrest you and that's why you need
to talk to my friends over at the u.s.
concealed carry Association right now
they're happy to give you for free when
you go to defend my family now calm the
20-17 concealed carry and family defense
guide it is from the US concealed carry
Association again it's a hundred percent
free you will learn how to detect
attackers before they see you how to
survive a mass shooting the safest and
most dangerous places to sit in a
restaurant how to responsibly own and
store a gun particularly if you have
kids and a whole lot more it's 164 pages
income and comes with a bonus audio
version so after you're done with our
podcast today you can go and listen to
that this life changing guide is a
hundred percent free for a limited time
you'll also get a bonus home defense
checklist so go to defend my family now
calm let's defend my family now calm and
get the resources that you need in order
to ensure that you are that you are
protected in case you god forbid have to
use your gun I mean the reason to own a
gun is that you don't have to use it if
God forbid II have to use it you need
help for my friends at the u.s. CCA
defend my family now calm okay so again
polarizing along trumpian lines usually
wouldn't be a problem for athletes
polarizing along trumpian lines when
Trump is standing with the flag and what
the Army is really not a good idea for
these athletes so here is here is Ben
Simmons who is seventy sixers forward I
believe talking about how much he hates
Trump if we were in Australia right now
a lot of people would call me that's how
I personally feel okay well that that's
convenience I mean again this is this
elevating the the discourse no and
listen I don't think anyone has an
obligation to elevate the discourse but
again if you're gonna polarize the
audience this is probably the best way
to do it so here's the problem
now the left has staked out a position
the position they staked out last Sunday
was it's good to Neil or it's good to
boycott the anthem
or as a slap against Trump we're gonna
do all of these things and then the fans
say wait
whatever you think about Trump what are
you doing with the anthem what are you
doing with the flag like these are the
only unifying symbols we have left we
disagree about everything we disagree
about politics we disagree about culture
we disagree about the the usefulness of
the pause pod we disagree about all
these things but what we don't disagree
about is the flag is a good thing in the
national anthem is a good thing so what
are you doing and so now the NFL has
basically been forced to back down the
way that they're backing down is that
they are standing and linking arms for
the national anthem this is this is
their sort of subtle way of backing down
I said that on Sunday what they should
have done if they wanted to show
solidarity is the people who are going
to kneel should have been the exact same
people kneeling six months ago and
everybody else on the field should have
stood next to the people who are
kneeling you're showing solidarity if I
sit by being next to the person right
what's the what's the big deal like why
is this why elevate the issue what's the
point of elevating the issue in any case
these players last night this is the
bears-packers game they were standing
and linking arms for the national anthem
and and this is a basically is a back
down rights back down people aren't
kneeling anymore ladies and gentlemen to
honor America please stand remove your
hats and join country recording artist
artist Tyler Farr as he sings our
National Anthem
[Applause]
[Music]
you see last week the dogs right and no
problem everybody's standing not a
problem but it looks like a back down
because once you stake out a position in
politics if you back off the position it
looks like the other guy won and it's
not just the Packers and the Bears this
is basically the new policy there's a
guy named Marquis Pouncy he is a is he a
linebacker for the Pittsburgh Steelers
he's a center he's the center for the
Pittsburgh Steelers and one of the
longest tenured players on their roster
he came out yesterday and he said I
promise you this week we are all gonna
stand for the anthem I promise you one
thing this week we'll all be standing
out there for the national anthem trust
me we respect our flag and we're
splittin military and everything that
goes a part of the men on I think the
bigger message that people were just
trying to stay out of it you know and
that we should have you know just United
inside and everyone was in there you
know standing up and it was all about
the flag and you know it's a big
misunderstanding I'm too trusting out
I'm very sorry to anyone that probably
feels the way that they do and you know
rightfully so but you know there's a lot
of arguments and then points but I care
about the flag dearly and they trust me
on this team right it's it's it
basically they're saying it was a big
mistake so that looks like a win for
Trump the the Denver Broncos put out
this message on their social media
yesterday they put out this long message
says last week members of our team
joined their brothers around the NFL in
a powerful display of unity it was an
emotional time for everyone including
the fans who support us each and every
week as controversial as it appeared we
needed to show our collective strength
and resolve our voices needed to be
heard loud and clear make no mistakes
our actions we're in no way a protest of
the military the flag of those who keep
us safe which is why if you thought that
then you shouldn't picked that example
it guys image matters you're in an image
driven business for goodness sake okay
it's not like you sell shoes for a
living all right you're actually in a
business where you are on TV all the
time
anyone in the TV industry knows that
what's on the TV is the image that
people are consuming
they say we have nothing but the deepest
love and respect for those who protect
our way of life and the freedoms we
enjoy as Americans while there's no
greater country it's not perfect
inequality still exists and we all have
work to do in all forms in social of
social justice which is their sort of
stop to to black
s'matter and then and then they say we
can all do better it starts with us and
then they say we are a team and we stand
together no matter how divisive some
comments and issues can be nothing
should ever get in the way of that
okay well as a country we're supposed to
stand together not just a team as a
country we're supposed to stand together
which is why people care about this
issue in the first place but again it
now looks like all these players who
note last week will not be kneeling this
week what prompted the change people are
going to say Trump did right so big win
for Trump big win for Trump the NBA's he
Adam silver he came out he said he now
expects the players to stand as coach
Popovich said the other day people need
to engage and have these discussions and
they're not always easy discussions to
have sometimes they are painful
discussions but they need to be had and
I'm hoping once again that this league
can play a constructive role there on
you know the anthem in specifically we
have a rule that requires our players to
stand for the anthem it's been our rule
as long as I've been involved with the
league and my expectation is that our
our players will continue to stand for
the anthem okay so nothing actually
changed in the NBA and this is the
important thing to note
it looks like the NBA is backing down
because some of the players were really
loud about this stuff but nothing
actually changed I mean in 1996 there
was a guy named Mahmoud Abdul Rauf he
was a guard for I believe it was the at
the time was he done the Golden State
Warriors or the Denver Nuggets he's I'm
Denver Nuggets at the time and he
refused to stand for the national anthem
instead he decided that he viewed the
American flag is a symbol of oppression
and racism and he said that standing for
the anthem anthem would conflict with
his Muslim faith he said you can't be
forgotten for oppression it's clear in
the Quran Islam is the only way I don't
criticize those who stand so don't
criticize me for sitting so the NBA
suspended him for a game and they cited
a rule that the players had to line up
in a dignified Pat posture it cost him
about 32 grand the Players Union
supported him and he reached a
compromise with the league that allowed
him to stand and pray with his head down
during the anthem and that was the end
of it that was the end of it you know he
his career basically tanked after that
because he lost his entire fan base but
that was basically the end of that so
the idea that this battle started just
last week is not really true or the idea
the NBA switched its position on this is
not really true but
impression left in the minds of the
public is that all these people were
going to kneel Trump stepped in they're
no longer kneeling good for Trump so big
political victory for Trump now is it a
big political victory for the right well
on the one hand a victory for Trump
against people who are kneeling is sort
of a victory for the right except that
more Americans thought that Colin
Kaepernick was doing a dumb thing before
Trump intervened then after he
intervened if you look at the polls
again there was like eighty-five percent
of Americans thought that Colin
Kaepernick was doing the wrong thing now
it's about 60% of Americans 65 percent
of Americans that's not actually a
victory for the right right it's
actually a loss for the right if I would
have told you that let's let's say that
Trump weren't president let's say that
Hillary had god forbid been elected
president and let's say that Hillary had
made comments talking about how
wonderful it was to kneel for the anthem
and the number of Americans who thought
it was bad to kneel for the anthem
dropped from 85 percent to 60 percent
who said that's a terrible thing 25%
more Americans now are okay with
kneeling for the anthem that's a really
bad thing well 25 percent of Americans
are now okay with kneeling for the
anthem that's not a great thing even
though Trump wins a political victory by
looking like a strong guy and it's not
really great for the country and this
was my objection in the first place
again a lot of people on the right
saying oh we're winning the culture war
we're winning the culture war so in the
one sense I think the right is winning
the culture war by demonstrating that
the left is willing to be this radical
that is a win for the right okay that's
a win for the right if the left is
willing to side with Colin Kaepernick
just to oppose Trump it demonstrates how
radical they are if the left is willing
to kneel for the anthem to to buck
against Trump that demonstrates the
radicalism of the left but for for
America's unity for the cause of
standing for the anthem it actually was
not a huge win so it's a little bit more
complex than just saying Trump wins
everybody else loses
we're done here I don't think it's quite
that simple now I want to talk about
what else this means in terms of the
Republican agenda stalling because well
Trump is fighting these culture war
battles that really get the base jazzed
up and get people excited because the
truth is as I've said before people are
much more interested in talking about
cultural issues than in tax cuts are the
Republicans even going to be able to do
anything and what is the divide inside
the Republican Party what does it even
mean what what like it's confusing
because you hear the term establishment
and then you see people who are clearly
not establishment being called
establishment and people who are working
with Nancy Pelosi and Chuck Schumer
being called
establishment what are these terms even
mean anymore Rush Limbaugh was on Sean
Hannity last night two guys who I've
been very friendly with and you know
people I grew up listening to and they
were talking about Trump versus sort of
the Republican Congress we'll get to
that in just a second but first I want
to say thank you to our sponsors over at
DaVinci so yesterday I was in Utah and
we didn't have a place to broadcast so
we use da Vinci to book a boardroom in
this really nice building beautiful
boardroom and we filmed from the
boardroom there for a very very low cost
that is what da Vinci does in today's
digital business world you may not have
offices you may not want to pay rent you
know like we do at this building for
offices you may have an online business
and you know you have a meeting now or
you have you have to Skype call somebody
and you don't want to look like you're
doing it from from your closet so
instead what you do is you go over to
DaVinci in you book a DaVinci meeting
room they provide you instant access to
over 5,000 incredibly affordable meeting
rooms in well-known office locations in
every city and they make it really easy
you search you book you meet and it's
what's amazing is that not only that The
DaVinci meeting room comes fully staffed
so we got there and there is actually an
assistant who is willing to Usher ready
to usher us into the room bring us
coffee it's like you have your own
office it's really amazing and equipped
with all the latest tech plus high-speed
Internet whether you need a day office
or a conference room a boardroom or a
training space DaVinci has what you need
to make your next business meeting a
success and those DaVinci meeting rooms
start at just 10 bucks an hour
so everyone listen we have offices but
when we're on the road we use DaVinci
I'm gonna go to Sacramento next week I'm
gonna use DaVinci right this is the way
that we operate here at the business and
that's how you should operate whether
you have offices or not if you don't
have offices it's even better because
then then no matter where you are you're
in your home city and you need an office
for the day just use DaVinci so right
now go to to Vinci meeting.com slash Ben
and the first hour is on them so the
first hour is free DaVinci meeting.com
slash Ben your first hour again is free
terms and conditions do apply for
details go to DaVinci meeting.com slash
Ben and you will see the place you hold
your next meeting is gonna be a lot
better than where you're holding it
right now DaVinci meeting.com slash Ben
really this is it's a great service and
yesterday's service was really
tremendous I mean it was like being at
home when we were on the road really
amazing ok so well Trump is engaged in
these culture wars which is the stuff
that animates elections let's let's be
frank about this what Republicans do on
tax cuts is gonna be much
less significant for the 2020 election
than this NFL stuff sorry that's just
the way it works
that's why Donald Trump can go from a
guy who was commenting on Twitter about
birtherism four years ago to the
President of the United States culture
wars matter a lot more than the
political battles but what does that
mean for the political battle in some
ways it means that it's harder to get
people on the same page because all you
have to do is virtue signal in the
culture wars and then we don't actually
have to pass anything so there are some
pretty significant and fundamental
differences inside the Republican Party
and it's it's always interesting to
watch people like like Shawn and Rush
both of whom have been strongly
supportive of President Trump talk about
what the Republican Congress is doing to
buck Trump instead of suggesting that
everyone has a duty to get on the same
page the idea is that if the Republicans
would just follow Trump he would lead
them to the promised land I don't think
that this is exactly correct I don't see
them embracing strong ideas and going
and selling them which I think they'd
win on the I don't think they're
conservative I don't think they ever
have been they don't want Trump to
succeed with his agenda they can't
afford that I'm not I'm not exaggerating
here if they don't want they can't
afford for him to succeed with his
agenda they can't afford it the lids
blown the gig is over the joke is
revealed if an outsider with no prior
political experience can come in and fix
messes that people have been promised
would be fixed for 30 years how does
that make them look they can't allow
that bang okay so the rush is actually
making a slightly different point he's
not making the point about conservatism
he's making a point that there are all
these career politicians who haven't
been doing anything if Trump comes in
and fixes thing he makes them look bad I
don't think that that's actually what's
going on here I don't think there are a
lot of career politicians who are
sitting around going you know what if I
for Trump I look better today how many
Republicans feel like if they thwart
Trump on things they want past that that
is actually gonna make them look better
in the eyes of their own constituents
their constituents voted for Trump their
constituents voted for Trump if they
look like they're actively thwarting
Trump they get ousted I mean hell if
they look like the they even signal did
not liking Trump they get ousted right
mo Brooks people forget about mo Brooks
in Alabama mo Brooks is much more
conservative than either Luther strange
or Roy Moore on policy and mo Brooks
who's a real Tea Party guy was came in
third in the in the Republican primary
because he wasn't supportive enough from
so this idea
all these guys are you know trying to
buck Trump to demonstrate that politics
is a hard business I don't think that's
right the problem with the argument
that's being made here is that Trump's
agenda is actually not the conservative
agenda this has always been the problem
this is the problem before the election
let's say the Republicans went along
with all of Trump's agenda and they just
started voting for it they'd be voting
for higher taxes on people who are who
are actually paying the taxes they'd be
voting for bigger spending they would be
voting for presumably a giant
infrastructure bill they would be voting
for immigration policy that their own
constituents in many cases don't support
they would be voting for president
Trump's program with regard to to
foreign policy has been all over the
place like Trump doesn't have a
well-defined program where he can even
even say follow-the-leader Rush says
that I mean rush admits the Trump's tax
policy is pure populism and then he says
that Republicans won't pass it because
it's pure populism maybe that's not a
terrible thing I mean if the tax
policies populism
I wasn't aware that these guys were
elected on a populist message they were
elected on a different message what it
really is is how to get votes in the
middle class with that bad and this is a
pure populist approach this is not a
conservative approach to tax reform
whatsoever on this one president Trump
is who he is he is a full-fledged
Nationals populist in this tax policy
says here sort of I think disagree with
what he was saying in the first clip and
the first clip he's saying these guys in
Congress they aren't conservative if
they're conservative they just go along
with Trump then he's admitting that
Trump's tax policy is pure populism you
can't really have it both ways
okay Trump's tax policy here when he's
saying he wants to raise the taxes on
the people who are paying the majority
of the taxes in the country you know
that is not a conservative thing to do
so what and and you know all of the
hubbub around trump and trumpism in this
idea of nationalist populism Trump is
into nationalist populist Trump is just
a guy with a bunch of use this idea of
putting like a philosophical patina on
trump's collection of viewpoints is
wrong like sometimes he does stuff that
super conservative I have to stop here
and praise Trump yesterday he nominated
Justice Don Willett of the Texas Supreme
Court to the Fifth Circuit Court of
Appeals great that's terrific
he also nominated a judge whose last
night and he's an Asian judge named
thing his last name is Ho and he was
nominated also he's also
quite conservative Trump's judicial
nominees have been across the board very
conservative that's been fantastic
but Trump isn't a conservative right so
that the point that I'm making here is
not that he doesn't get credit for that
he absolutely does that's a wonderful
thing he should continue nominating
terrific justices to fill these slots
but the suggestion that that Trump is
across the board a consistent guy or he
has any sort of through lines what he
believes is just not true Ann Coulter's
I think he's sort of making the same
mistake here
again I've known Ann since I was 16
years old here's Ann talking about Roy
Moore the guy who just won the Alabama
Senate primary
I was very controversial because not
only did he bring in a ten commandments
a ten commandments monument and put it
on the lawn at the Alabama Judicial at
the state courthouse I guess he refused
to remove it when he was ordered to
remove it and he was he was ousted from
his job there then he got his job back
then he refused to enforce same-sex
rules promulgated by the Supreme Court
of the United States and then he was
ousted again he's made some pretty
ridiculous comments about people like
keith Ellison not being able to be
seated in Congress because keith Ellison
is a Muslim
that's absurd I really dislike keith
Ellison I think Keith Allison is an
awful person but I don't think that
Muslims should not be allowed to sit in
Congress I think that's that's silly but
in any case here's Ann Coulter on Roy
Moore talking about what happened in
Alabama because remember Roy Moore was
the guy who was not endorsed by Trump
Luther Strange was the guy endorsed by
Trump but Roy Moore beat Luther strange
pretty handily here's here's Coulter how
are you doing how are you Mark saloon oh
you sound happy today ISM prevailed my
candidate I I don't know anything about
Alabama's Senate candidates they look
like to Andy Griffith has not been
following Trump is and we now see there
are two different things
[Music]
this is and this is the the message that
people are trying to do now so now that
it's clear that Trump does not actually
have an ideology people are trying to
actually construct one and then separate
it from Trump I'll call it trumpism
which is incoherent what really unifies
the party you want to know why the
Republican Party is having difficulty
governing the reason they're having
difficulty governing is because the only
unifying thread
between Trump and the trumpets the
people who like trumpism or whatever
they're calling that these days the
National is populist and the people who
are traditional conservatives and
libertarians the only thing that unites
them is opposition to the left
that's not a great thing okay listen we
don't what we're not big on the left
here I mean we said we give you a mug
right that says leftist here is hot or
cold like this is what we're not huge on
the left but you actually have to push a
certain ideology if you hope to unify
actually be able to govern the fact that
Republicans are not really speaks to the
idea that opposition is a lot easier
than governing and this is where Trump's
I keep saying this over and over mr.
president
you campaigned as a leader you
campaigned as the guy who was gonna lead
Republicans to the promised land the guy
who's gonna get things done
forget about the first part let's just
talk about getting things done if you
want to get things done you need to
buckle down and you need to force
through your agenda by taking it
directly to the public and by wheeling
and dealing what you say you're great at
you need to do all of these things
because otherwise it's just gonna be the
Republicans unable to to push an agenda
and you sitting on the sidelines sniping
at them that's not a recipe for for
legislative success in any way shape or
form well we're gonna get the things I
like things I hate in the mailbag but
first you're gonna have to subscribe if
you want to see that live so you can
always listen later on audio but if you
wanted to subscribe and see the rest of
the show live any part of the mailbag
get your questions in then go over to
daily wire com $9.99 a month we'll get
you a subscription to the daily wearing
it my show you get Andrew Clavin show
you got Michael Knowles to show you get
all of those shows fully live you can
download them later ad free when you are
a subscriber you can also get our
website without banner ads you get all
those things when you subscribe if you
become any annual subscriber you get
this the aforementioned greatest vessel
for holding tiers in the known universe
the leftist here is hot or cold tumblr
and and you can use that to your heart's
content for $99 a year if you just want
to listen to the show for free later go
over to iTunes or SoundCloud or YouTube
subscribe leave us a review we always
appreciate it we got er the largest
fastest growing podcast in the nation
[Music]
should say were the fastest-growing
largest fast growing conservative
podcast in the nation in any case let's
talk about some things I like and some
things that I hate so one of the things
that is really it's it's pretty
fascinating actually
about the way that we approach racial
issues in this country today is we look
we sort of put a different spin on
history in the 1960s and 70s than what
was actually being lived at the time so
at the time the people who are actually
making a dent we're not people like
Malcolm X it was people like Martin
Luther King those are the people who are
convincing good-hearted white folks to
join on the bandwagon not a lot of white
folks were joining Martin Malcolm X's
bandwagon a lot of white folks for
joining Martin Luther King's bandwagon
as well they should have that was the
right choice okay in the 1960s and 70s
the move toward racial reconciliation by
the media was an attempt toward
reconciliation not toward the idea that
we have to continue dividing ourselves
that we can be more self aware and this
will lead to reconciliation but the idea
that white people and black people
treating each other as individuals was
the way forward right which is a
traditionally American idea now I want
to contrast the way that the football
universe is acting today with no black
players have to kneel because they see a
different flag than white players and
white players have to stand by black
players who kneel because they have to
respect the black people see a different
flags and white people that sort of
ideology promoted by Dan Patrick a
couple of days ago contrast that with
what the media we're trying to do back
in the 1970s so this is one of the most
famous TV movies of all time it's a TV
TV movie called Brian's song with a
great cast it's James Caan and Billy Dee
Williams this comes out in 1971 it is at
the time I believe the biggest and
highest-rated TV movie of all time and
it is about Gale Sayers who's a the
famous running back for the Chicago
Bears and Brian piccolo a backup running
back for the Chicago Bears and it's all
rid of the whole movies about racial
reconciliation and again this is when
the media was actually trying to promote
racial reconciliation rather than racial
division in the name of racial
reconciliation so here's Brian song
which is a very moving good movie
[Music]
this is a story about two men they
competed for the same job one was white
the other black one like to talk a lot
you said uh-huh
the other was shy as a three-year-old
mmm rookies got to stick together
our stories about how they came to know
each other fight each other I'm gonna
whip you shares but you gotta be at your
best and help each other I think I owe
you beer hell you a lot more than that
yeah what actually happened a true story
Brian piccolo ended up with cancer and
he died I think it's like 31 or
something and they actually interviewed
Gale Sayers about Brian piccolo said the
movie was pretty accurate as far as our
relationship and what Brian piccolo
was like sports can be something that
unifies us sports culture these these
should be unifying factors and not
dividing factors it's one of the Pet
peds for the write we look at culture
when we say listen that should be
bringing us together you know we can
have uplifting stories like this yes of
course we can tell stories about
terrible things that have happened black
people in the past and happened to black
people in the present but we also need a
message of reconciliation or we're never
gonna be able to move beyond this this
is what Obama promised in 2008 and then
didn't deliver over the next eight years
instead opting for the intersectional
politics of the left that suggest that
America is innately divided and can
never be reconciled that's a disaster
area and this is it's a really good
movie it's very moving film so Brian's
song you can go check that out okay
other things that I like speaking of
unit things that should be unifying
Steve Scalise the Louisiana Congress
person who was shot by the Bernie
Sanders supporter again not Bernie's
fault as I've said a thousand times but
he was shot by a guy who's a far leftist
in the Congressional baseball shooting
he finally came back to the house
yesterday after a long recovery and here
he was arriving there
[Applause]
Thank You mr. speaker you have no idea
how great this feels to be back here at
work in the people's house
you know and that's definite moments
that we like this that we have to
remember that again I keep going back to
the Lincoln Line we we must be brothers
otherwise we're gonna be enemies and and
this is a good example of that okay time
for some quick things I hate and then we
will go to the mailbag already so let's
begin the things I hate with the this
bit of amazing journalism by steven
crowder and his producer not gay Jared I
actually not gay Jared has been urging
me to follow him for well over a year on
Twitter I finally followed him last
night to his life is complete so here's
what here's why the reason I did is
because he actually infiltrated an Tifa
over at University of Utah and you can
see he was there he put on a wig he put
on contact and they went they got
encrypted apps from the front again Tifa
wouldn't allow them in unless they got
encryption on their phone and they were
messaging each other here is actual
video of an auntie feh member offering
Steven Crowder's producer a knife and
then you'll see you'll see I'm not sure
if this is a man or woman it's a
transgender person offer the the knife
and then an ice pick the person is
carrying a Taser and it also suggests
that if things go wrong then they should
retreat to a car where there are a k47 s
in the back
here with Fox 13 News
we've been tracking anthem for a long
time he was just down there at
president's circle and they were handing
out sharp objects to staff people with
so they had someone coming with an 8k
why did it take - late night host
comedians to find this out hey you know
what I wish you guys luck
okay so what's it what's amazing is that
you go watch the full footage over at
louder with Crowder we also posted it
last night at daily wire and you'll see
that the girl goes out and girl a guy
again I'm not sure about this person but
this person this person offers that and
then says no not only do you have to - a
case coming one of the other people says
we have a sawed-off shotgun okay so out
of shotguns are illegal under all law
okay there's not there's not a state in
the Union that allows sawed-off shotguns
and and they were offering this I guess
that the Crowder's producer said
knocking Jarrod went to the when's the
cops after this he basically said guys I
gotta go to the bathroom and then he
immediately went to the police and the
police came and arrested these people
but it is amazing and it is amazing that
that again you know I think more
journalistic outlets should be doing
work like this one of the things that I
talk about when I talk about journalism
is that there's an attempt by the media
to separate acts of journalism from
being a journalist so say well my career
is I'm a journalist okay fine fair but
then there's a suggestion that if you're
not a journalist and you go and do an
act of journalism like Crowder's doing
crowder again as a comedian and not gay
Gerardus producer that that is not
journalism because they are not
quote-unquote journalists right they
don't have the magic journalists fairy
dust and therefore they don't get that
credit okay you get credit for breaking
the story when you break the story this
is a story okay when auntie fizz
offering your knife that's a story these
people are not nonviolent they are quite
violent and they're quite willing to
engage in violence okay one more thing I
hate and we'll get to them the food one
more thing I hate and get something like
okay one more one more thing I hate okay
so that is Jimmy Kimmel last night I
hate to rip on Jimmy Kimmel so much
lately because I think Jimmy Kimmel is a
talented guy but Jimmy Kimmel he he did
a whole tribute to Hugh Hefner and
yesterday if you wanted my take on Hugh
Hefner I did 20 minutes on Hugh Hefner
yesterday go listen to yesterday's
podcast the short take is everybody is
treating a seedy old pornographer like
he was some sort of great force in
American life for good and here's Jimmy
Kimmel saying about a guy who
legitimately was worse to women than
Donald Trump by about a thousand times
I mean his grotto was was described as a
sex prison by people who used to work
there
here's Jimmy Kimmel talking about how
wonderful Hugh Hefner was and he'll be
disappointed he'll be disappointed after
he dies and goes to heaven I was
thinking about last night Hugh Hefner's
probably the only person ever to be
disappointed by heaven with all these
harps let's get some naked girls in here
okay first of all a couple of
suggestions I think it's highly doubtful
that the place if there is an afterlife
that Hugh Hefner will end up is
initially heaven but in any case this
this idea the Jim that Hugh Hefner is
just somebody we joke about Hugh Hefner
he may have helped individual women who
are trying to make their way in the
world he was not good for women as a
whole and he was not good for men as a
whole the pornography
porn porn if ocation of american culture
has not been a good thing for men who
become desensitized to sex and treat
women as sex objects more often because
they see more naked women all the time
airbrushed naked women in most of these
cases and it's not been great for women
who are seen is the objects by by these
guys I mean it has not been good for the
culture so the celebration of Hugh
Hefner is quite odd these are the same
people who when clay Travis had first
amendment in boobs and CNN Oh Garrick
Lake Travis sexism sexism Hugh Hefner
was one bajillion times as sexist as
clay Travis I mean legitimately pretty
pretty incredible and by the way there's
an awful article over Politico today
saying that Clay Travis is somehow an
alt writer and then they provide no
evidence that he's actually an alt
writer I guess that he's an alt writer
because he says that kneeling for the
flag is bad and that Trump is right I
may disagree with them but that doesn't
make you alright okay in any case let's
get to the mailbag again if you're
subscriber
right your left right your your messages
now and we will do something live okay
Isaac says I'm 21 I have no idea what I
want to do with my life I have no real
interest either how do I find out what I
should do for my career well you're
asking me if you're like a lump if
you're like an amoeba what should you do
with your life um so you have no real
interest and you have no idea what you
want to do with your life and I'm
supposed to fix that for you so normally
I fix your problems let me start with
this one if you are bored with things
it's because you're boring okay if
you're bored with life it's because you
haven't searched enough if you decide to
be bored with life you're not gonna make
a career or a happy life out of being
bored so you do have to find something
that you are enthusiastic
about something that you're interested
in listen you're interested enough to
become a subscriber to this show which
means that you're obviously interested
in pop culture and politics so there's
certain things you're interested in you
know you may not be interested in
becoming an electrical engineer but
there's certain aspects of life that you
are interested in enough and fascinated
enough to engage with you need to find
out what those are and what aspect of
that you can be good with and there's so
much crossover in the economy right can
be interested in politics and you don't
have to sit behind a mic like me you can
you know we have people who cut audio
for us we have people who do animation
for us we have people who produce the
show we have people who travel with me
on the road we have million you know
like there are lots of different jobs in
this in this milieu so if you're
interested in this kind of stuff there
are lots of different jobs that fulfill
different skill sets what I say to
everybody find your passion and then
find the skill set that matches your
passion and that's the best way to have
a happy life
Julia says dear Ben my parents are Bali
too about this is Jews who become
religious violate you teshuva means
owners of repentance literally does most
of my siblings have left religion I'm
the only one still as religious as my
parents I'm also 14 so I don't have much
of a choice why do children of both
ultra-religious parents abandon religion
so I think one of the reasons is that
ultra religious parents very often don't
feel there's a real balance in the
religious community between Kroy
stirring your child and exposing them to
ideas so that you can inoculate them
against bad ideas right you understand
why people feel that there's a seduction
to secular culture there is I mean you
get to do whatever you want right all
the time you get to do whatever you want
sounds great except that you may not
find fulfilment in that sometimes acting
with virtue is the place you actually
find fulfillment but let's say that
you're an 18 year old kid and you've
only lived in an ultra-orthodox
community lives in a car ad community
for example and you decide you're gonna
go to college and suddenly people are
saying to you things like well have you
ever considered the time I may not have
happened or have you ever considered
that and that the Bible is a book of
myth or have you ever considered that
religion may be false altogether and God
doesn't exist it you can do whatever you
want and hey look they're a bunch of hot
girls let's go to a party right these
things actually affect people who are
religious and this is why I think it's
very important to have open and honest
conversations about the nature of faith
about the nature of your faith about why
it is that going to the party with the
hot girls it may be worth forgoing that
in order so that you have a better life
in the future like I have a very
fulfilled wife thank God I have a very
fulfilled life that was
until I was 24 right I was married at 24
to my wife she was 20 and I am very
pleased with that decision she was a
virgin as well I do not have a single
shred of regret that I didn't go to
college parties and drink myself
senseless and have sex with random
people I have no regret about that I
don't have regret about that because I
think that I've chosen a better way of
life and I think that you have to feel
that you are defending a higher truth in
order for you to feel as though you're
doing something valuable and not be
seduced by outside forces so people tend
to react to the outside forces by closed
during themselves that only makes them
more vulnerable it's sort of like the
polio virus in the 1930s well one of the
funny things about polio viruses that it
tended to affect it tended to inflict
more damage on people who are very
wealthy than people who are very poor
and people wondering why is that well
the answer is that a lot of poor people
were playing outside in the mud and
exposing themselves to germs they'd
stronger immune systems and a lot of the
rich kids weren't if you if you keep a
kid a baby in a bubble and they they
never have to deal with with antigens
then there's there's never going to be a
situation in which their immune system
is developed enough for them to actually
fight those things off you have to
expose your kids to enough ideas that
are foreign to your culture and then
defend your culture against those that
your kids have heard it before
and it's nothing new and seductive by
the way I feel this way about when you
talk to your kids about sex I think that
half of the half of the things that go
wrong with regard to kids and sex is
that we say to kids wait you can't talk
about that it's secret it's mysterious
when you take the mystery out of sex
then you're actually injecting the love
back into sex meaning that sex is not
anything mysterious it's a biological
function
all right certain parts going in certain
places when you remove the mystery from
sex what you end up doing is suggesting
that in order for it to be more than
that there needs to be some sort of
feeling attached to the sex I think the
mistake a lot of religious parents make
city well we can't talk about that well
you can't talk about that right there
yeah that's dirty that's dirty talk we
can't talk about it and then kids Google
it's dirty sounds great all right that's
it so I think it's a big mistake not to
be open and honest with your kids about
this kind of stuff Mitch says what is
your favorite musical period classical
romantic etc and why well I think
probably the border between classical
and romantic so for people don't know
classical music that well classical
music was basically from there's the
Baroque period which is sort of Bach and
then there's the Classical period which
is considered Mozart and Beethoven
Beethoven really sort of spans the
divide between
classical and romantic and by the tenets
of Tchaikovsky and Brahms here in the
Romantic period so Beethoven is the best
composer who ever lived
although there is a strong argument for
Bach the the most listenable music in
terms of just you turn on the radio and
you in you and it's easy listening is is
baroque / classical music by Bach that
that's if I had to pick one composer to
take to a desert island it would be Bach
Benjamin says hey Ben I've been reading
up on Israel and I'm becoming frustrated
with the fact that Israel's public
perception has shifted so negatively
when it's blatantly obvious that they
are not the hostile actors in the region
when did this shift in public opinion
occur who are the main proponents of it
so the major shift in public opinion did
not occur in the last ten years it
occurred in 1967 before that Israel is
considered a small nation fighting for
its survival in a community of nations
seeking to destroy it and after 67 when
Israel was dominance in the six-day war
then a lot of the left suggested that
Israel was now the oppressor because
Israel was powerful and also Israel was
bad because it wasn't socialist enough
because that was about the time the
Soviet Union realized that they were
gonna try and make inroads in the Arab
community by making nice with people
like Nasser who was the head of Egypt at
the time and in doing so they sort of
posed Israel as a mini America and
people hate America and Israel for
basically the same reason if they if
they hate Israel now Chris has hey Ben
if you were trying to get into politics
on a local level what would be a good
position to begin a political career
well it depends on your your
neighborhood I would say the easiest
place to get in is usually something
like the school board you know someplace
where there five thousand voters because
there you can actually do direct
outreach to all the people who are
voting it's enough people you can
actually shake all the hands of every
voter that you want to vote for you and
then once you're on the school board you
can actually do some good hopefully for
the students and that usually seems like
a good way to to promote your career
Kathy says I have a family member who's
in a lesbian relationship raising a baby
and I have two children under 4 I don't
want my children to be confused by
seeing this how do I handle holidays
well I mean I think that you should
honestly have an open conversation with
your lesbian relative I think that's
perfectly fair I think it's perfectly
fair confusing small children about
about heterosexuality versus
homosexuality seems to me a really bad
move because if you're trying to
inculcate a set of values and you say
that it is that it is better for for
your child to be straight than gay which
is a perfectly respectable non home
fallback position just talking about
what will lead to your perception of
human happiness that's not irrational in
any way if you if you say to this to
this lesbian family member listen you're
welcome to come over you know you're
welcome to say that this is that this is
your partner right this is a person who
you live with but you know we don't like
using the word wife because I don't want
to explain to my child that because I
don't believe in same-sex marriage right
the state may but I don't and I don't
want to I don't want my child to believe
in that either and that's my right as a
parent you can either respect my rights
as a parent or we can meet privately off
away from the kids like this is a matter
of parental rights and parental right
you don't have a right to teach my kid
anything I have a right to teach my kid
what I want it's my kid
Jessica says happy Friday Ben yesterday
you said if you haven't wrestled with
your doubts you're not religious is
there a particular time you wrestle more
heavily with your faith and what brought
you assurance thanks for always being
the voice of reason during the non-stop
carousel of leftist crazy so it's kind
of weird for me um when I wrestle with
doubts the doubts that I tend to wrestle
with our doubts about how much of faith
can be based on rationality and how much
of faith has to be based on faith so
there's never been a time where I've
where I've really thought where I've
really thought that God didn't exist
I've wondered whether there's a rational
basis for God's existence and that's
where I'm really doubtful I also have
never responded to tragedy that has
occurred in my family by doubting God's
existence that's just it's a lot of
people do a lot of people see terrible
terrible things and they doubt God's
existence I've never really had a
problem with the theodicy part of the
issue the issue that why if God exists
why does evil exist it seems to me that
God created a system where freewill has
to exist which means that he has to
shield himself because if everything God
did were immediately visible in terms of
acts and consequences freewill would go
by the wayside that said you know I
think that that's why I'm constantly
reading about religion a little bit
later today actually I'm into a Facebook
live where the professor a professor
named Edward phasor and I welcome you to
go over our Facebook page and watch he
wrote a book called five proofs of God's
existence and I want to talk to him
about those proofs and what they mean
and how much of faith can actually be
based on reason and how much you you
have to actually take a leap of faith I
would also say that one of the things
that brings me a little bit of comfort
here maybe it's foolish but I think this
is but I think that it's it's true
anyway is that every system of thought
has leaps of faith attached to it sam
harris has as many leaps of faith in his
system of thought as I do and
what'll be fun is I'm doing an event
with Sam Harris in December in San
Francisco we're gonna sell it it's like
2500 seats and we're gonna talk about
all these things freewill religion it
should be a blast I look forward to it
Sam's a good guy Madison says hi Ben
thanks for signing my canvas when I met
you in June what's your position on
physician assisted suicide should it be
legal is it moral what is the best
argument against it so it seems to me
that the best argument against physician
assisted suicide is that his physician
assisted so I think there's an
interesting moral argument with regard
to assisted suicide in general like the
truth is that when we have palliative
care it's not assisted suicide formally
because we're not injecting enough
morphine to Kelly but we're basically
making you comfortable until you die
putting physician assisted suicide on
the table means that you have to start
drawing lines now even people who are in
favor of a physician assisted suicide
usually will want to require that the
person who is receiving the physician
assisted suicide should have to go
through some sort of background check
that if you're an 11 year olds he's
having thoughts of suicide but you're
perfectly healthy in every way that we
shouldn't allow you to do that
well now you're putting your standards
on the person who wants to commit the
suicide which denies the fundamental
argument you're making about autonomy so
that's sort of interesting
I don't think doctors should be in the
business of death I don't think doctors
should be competing to see who can
deliver death the cheapest price in a
free market and doctors should be there
to heal your suicide also you should be
taking culpability for your own suicide
it shouldn't be on a doctor to have to
take culpability for killing you all
right Joseph says hi Ben lots of
non-religious that.i people people that
I meet attempt to discredit the Bible by
bringing up violent verses that call for
things like stoning disobedient children
and people who send in general how do
you combat points like these especially
if you're unfamiliar with those verses
so first of all you have to be familiar
with the voice verses in order to in
order to fight back against miss
readings of the verses if you don't know
that much about it you say listen I want
to go do the research on the verse
forgive me if I don't take your opinion
as gospel truth on this particular verse
since you obviously have an axe to grind
let me do the research maybe I'll have a
response on those particular verses by
the way the Talmud says that no child
has ever been has never been held
accountable for what they call Ben surah
or Mora which is the the rebellious
child who is stoned also all of the
death penalty offenses in the Bible
require according to Jewish law anyway
two eyewitnesses who not only witness
the event but warn the person beforehand
all right they actually warn the person
they say do not kill that man and the
guy says
screw you I'm gonna kill him and then
they both see that and they both see the
guy then they go and testify so this is
why it also says in the Talmud that a
Beit din a Sanhedrin that issued a death
penalty once every 70 years was
considered a murderous Beit din so the
all of the talk about you know all the
death penalty stuff in the Bible was
really not applied it was it was an
attempt to express that rebellion
against God in participation in sin is
worthy of death that's really what it's
about Chris says what do you believe
will be Trump's most likely legislation
to pass during this term it seems health
care is behind us for now and tax
reforms on shaky ground as well I think
at some point he's just gonna turn to
infrastructure he's gonna grab bout 20
Republicans and 40 Democrats and try to
ram through a giant infrastructure
package it's quite possible though that
the political landscape is so polarized
at this point that the Democrats are
saying we're not gonna help you with
anything and then nothing passes and
it's an amazing statement to make about
about a president that nothing passes
but we're now through year one and
that's where the president's political
capital is highest and nothing's passing
Antonia says do you or Antonia says you
been do you think the number of sexual
partner one has before marriage is
important does having more partners
lower the chances of you having a
successful marriage well the data tend
to show that the more promiscuous you
are before marriage the less likely it
is that you're gonna be happy inside of
marriage the data also tend to show that
if you live with somebody for a long
time before marriage or divorce rate is
higher this idea you have to try out a
partner before you get married I think
it's just idiocy the reason being that
that's what dating is for but the idea
that you have to try somebody out to be
sexually compatible I have real serious
problems with this you know the I don't
want to get too graphic here but let me
just suggest that I think that there is
a solid correlation unless you have like
a serious sexual dysfunction which is
something that you probably would know
beforehand or if you don't know
beforehand there are treatments for then
the idea that you are sexually
incompatible generally means that you're
personally incompatible as well if these
are all issues that should be discussed
upfront but this this making sex super
complicated like you have to try it out
because your cuz you're comparing cars
it seems like idiocy to me first of all
if you and the person that you're having
sex with have hadn't had no basis for
comparison then it's the best sex you've
both ever had so that's so that there is
that convenient little fact you know if
the only beer you've ever had is Bud
Light is the greatest beer you've ever
had
so they say you don't really have to
worry about but also I think sexual
compatibility is really more just about
being willing to give just being a
giving person and if you're a giving
person then sexual compatibility is
actually pretty easy Seth says what is
the appropriate legal route to take for
an individual that believes there is
racism taking place within a work
environment what this process be costing
well usually there's state or federal
laws anti-discrimination laws you can
file a lawsuit if they violate those
discrimination laws one of the questions
that I have is whether those laws should
be on the books in the first place not
because I'm Pro discrimination I hate
discrimination but because in a free
market I think that discrimination
should be punished by other businesses
destroying the discriminatory business
in open competition but the appropriate
legal route to take just as a lawyer is
you'd have to actually go look at the
applicable state or federal law and see
if it's technically been violated Vinson
says for a guy in the workplace how many
buttons can be undone on a collared
button-up shirt and a Social Scene a bar
a barbecue family event how many buttons
can be undone - thank you so my answer
is exactly the same in either case you
see the number of buttons that I
currently have undone the answer is one
do not be Michael Knowles
don't do it okay this is nonsense where
you can button your shirt down to your
navel look at me okay like no one wants
to see that no one wants to see that if
they wanted to see that they'd be
married to you okay the idea that you
should be walking around with your with
your shirt undone and that it's
comfortable social scene just like a
mensch and if you want if you don't want
to wear a button-down shirt then put on
a t-shirt okay like I don't understand
why modesty is gone by the wayside for
everybody like it no one wants to see
that really if they want to see it then
they should then they should be willing
to put a ring on it as the great
prophetess Beyonce one side okay so now
so we will be back here next week on
Monday so next week I'm warning you now
so that you have fair warning
we are doing shows Monday Tuesday
Wednesday then I'm gone for a week and a
half a week and a half because I'm
finally taking my long-awaited vacation
it's a Jewish holiday so I'd be missing
some of those days anyways I'm taking
the vacation during the Jewish holiday
I'm really technically missing only like
a couple of days that I wouldn't be able
to died be able to broadcast anyway but
that means that next week you're going
to have to listen up and listen good
because if you're going to fix things
while I'm gone then you're going to need
to listen to my words of advice very
clearly and you need to put your ear
very close to your phone and you're
going to need to
that everything that I say is correct
because for a week and a half I will not
be here to guide you when I come back
down from the top of the mountain I will
bring you a set of Commandments okay
then I'm getting a little bit over my
over my skis all right well we'll be
back here on Monday I'm Ben Shapiro this
is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]